[Music]
rain
a pulls out a classic during her Super
Bowl halftime performance that's what
this show is going to be it's going to
be a celebration of my catalog in in the
best way that we could have put it
together
[Music]
the Navy knows Rihanna released umbrella
back in 2007 featuring Jay-Z
no Jay where are you at the rapper
unfortunately didn't join Rihanna on
stage to perform the hit despite him
being at the big game with daughter Blue
Ivy working with Jay and having a
collaboration with him is it's just one
of those things that everyone dreams to
do in their musical career and here I am
at 19 years old with the number one
single and featuring Jay-Z is just I
can't fathom it sometimes it's just too
much for me to it's overwhelming
sometimes maybe Rihanna wanted to bring
hope out but it must be hard squeezing
us so much into a halftime show you only
have 13 minutes that's the challenge so
you're trying to cram
17 years of work into 13 minutes so it's
it's difficult oh and there was this to
squeeze in too yeah Rihanna revealed
she's pregnant with a baby number two
during her set it's an Entertainer's
dream to be on a stage like that but
it's nerve-wracking you want to get it
right you know everybody's watching
and they're rooting for you you can say
that again everyone watched as the
singer lovingly cradled her baby bump
throughout the performance I really
feels Like A lot's happening all at once
it feels like motherhood
Oscars Super Bowl I'm still pinching
myself really I'm grateful I'm grateful
foreign